bernhard laundry
television journal of the important
because of the hour brought to you every
monday wednesday and friday
presentation of the laundry list of what
happened
later on
laundry the world's most al-kidwa
and with
distinguished companions of the world on
its own g
remains but the fact that
mary introduce our part of it for this
edition of the mounting kosto
mister william bradford giri editor of
the american mercury
and mister cochran
france editor of newsweek magazine
our distinguished guests for this
evening is a horrible todd bridges
united states senate up on your answer
the opinions expressed are necessarily
those of the speaker
so to britain as i'm sure there are
jurors will be glad to hear back from
the commercial again tonight sir
and as republican leader in the united
states senate
why have we welcome your views on some
of the current developments
now for uh... senator past
and in a rather important meeting with
general eisenhower
and hear that you're interested in that
and i'd like to tell our viewers just
uh... what you think
was the result of that meeting between
uh...
general and how intensive care
i think it brought together
tour of the great factions of the
republican party
and uh... i think that uh... there was a
general agreement as a result of the
comp
i think that that means that
role to perform a lot of the way the
eisenhower camdensafe
and i think that the differences which
you know that it may have had before as
a result of that conferences have been
sort of all that the area of deference
between the two
was flight
and the staff to do it for the effect
conference in or out of
would you think this mean any change in
the content of the campaign in high sec
if anything it will have a tendency of
the staff to step up the campaign
no preference in cleveland perfectly
either capital pinpoint the issues
uh... that he's uh... particularly
concerned web and uh... intends to
upon a very vigorous type of campaign of
course as uh... republican leader in the
senate i know that you yourself have
been uh... very intersted
and uh... you making the party
now do you foresee sure that uh...
by november the fourth you think that
you will have a united republican party
ideal yes i do a productive
you don't think that any of the uh...
so-called extreme right factions will
hold back
uh... from supporting general and more
effectively as you will probably stop
laptop five dr
that uh... the right
and conservative wing of the republican
party has perhaps exemplified by the tap
to fraction of the cap leadership
uh... role will be such a difference
creamy envy
left-wing temperatures of the democratic
campaign not
so they'll have no difficulty in
making that choice
they're there
extremely interesting development now a
that kind of course the smashing victory
of senator mccarthy
uh... in wisconsin
now early to tell our viewers there how
you interpret uh... the meaning of that
as a surprise i think that uh...
from atop this victory
wisconsin
by sector tremendous mott margin
indicates that the people of wisconsin
suddenly and awful hardly any objectives
which you saw which is to read the
government agents into this country of
subversive
alum clear suppressor at
here is our live project that magnitude
besides that i was not surprised at the
back
reportedly is a private garden which
product you prelim and mccarthy support
crying when during the campaign will be
valuable
well i think that as well because i
think people
to most people in the country mccarthy
one of the agreed with all of these
methods
all the defense
uh... they agree that uh... mccarthy is
out of a symbol of action the people on
action in eliminating the
bad influences the subversives from the
government of you know i don't know if
it's critically of course there you're
interested in electing republicans to
mandates in it
now do you think that mccarthy can be
useful outside wisconsin in the election
of republicans to the senate
yes i think you'd be interested in many
states union hall
where we have a republican karen
is there any place where he didn't
welcome
i think the only state that i've had
i've been particularly with the
statement coming out of connecticut
recently
where one of the candidates for all the
some of them that they indicated that
care
even can make use of sam and cokie you
regard that as a tactical error on the
part of the republicans in connecticut
ideal
yet would be a similar tactical error
for eisenhower the continued commitment
well i think i've maar as our character
must recognize uh...
looked out the victory there and uh...
it should not be sandwich magnitude is
there any reason to believe you will
i rather think that he will get
well senator in our viewers a number of
the mantra know that you yourself have
been making the number of uh...
trips out into the country and uh...
that you are supporting the ticket
actively
now uh... what
uh... interesting observation do you
have for us from those trips that you've
been making
well i uh... come audio
along with the definite feeling on
justin wrote back na from other a
lengthy crap
uh... that uh... the campaign republican
painstaking out gathering momentum
and uh...
if it uh...
the recent
camdensafe picked up to gather momentum
carry forward as i have every reason to
believe that as well
uh... i think it's a government
is there a difference between the things
that the people you spoken to are
interested in
and things out in our district since
caroline and i find that particular
people were rested and threatened
about medicare workers you private
reverend confederate interested in
career
and uh...
sorrow action manipulative railroad very
reluctant actually
that are interested in reading
delegate glimpses of the government from
all the communist
influences but until that they're very
intersted in and intact
if you think that's one of the major
issue yes i do a lot of literature
when they feel that was felt by
sometime around then and taxpayers
now ineffective because you are of
course there are a yankee in a new
england area is everybody in the country
is worried about money that you people
are are in a row up ignoring when we are
interested in money
we like to see the american dollar work
tomorrow
and we're getting married
i was over in canada or the other day
and uh...
but just an item for eight dollars
i gave mister shopkeeper eight dollars
and he said thirty two more sense body
god all written left is a much is yours
today when i was a shock to me by
because i was brought up
the new england faith along the canadian
bought it
involvement are my childhood on
the canadian dollar for a little bit
come up ten to fifteen frenchman mark in
dollar amount of crime that
uh... the american dollar selling of
those are not the canadian dollar to
perfect shop to make your senator larry
you've you have reviewed that in the
senate there said something like
nineteen thirty six and he liked your
number one and it by the time yes
meaning you've been there longer than
any other republican
uh...
and you're still a relatively young man
i believe
now fair
itinerant monthly returns null or a
great sense of a republican senate under
republican house i think if we have any
friend
in this election which i believe we have
that we have a untaxed income to capture
both the senate models but then it will
be by a small margin look we can capture
believe campaigns in the clinton the
house
differently from the national campaigns
for about an overall will be that same
but there are of the individual
candidates in the respective states
well emphasized the looked at your own
pacific issue
are coming back to your steps
uh... you regard yourself as a
conservative in the united states senate
now when i came to the east on it
to from the government here from new
hampshire up there i was regarded as
perot's
regretted
unfold most people did i ever got me
ultraconservative argumentative changes
that may make you are opposed to the
so-called schoolgirl at all and if
there's anything that makes me sick and
tired of stab
uh... democrat from new dealers
all around this country thailand of the
republican field and they'll turn back
the pages
of uh... tubely docking ages
sure undiluted bob
and uh... as a matter of fact
through republicans generally it
probably
song social getting than anything in
your own record that indicates that i
guess when i was governor of new
hampshire
uh... my faith
but while the state of new hampshire was
the first state in the united states to
qualify under the federal social
security act
we put through the first of this
economic climate insurance law in the
country
we put through mother's leg which was a
moment to step in the country and we fed
up with us
cancer research
uh... commission
and uh... planets in the capital of the
republican chairman of the social gains
local social beings legislations differ
from the democratic
well i think that there are uh... that's
a good point
i think the the republicans
would like to see
cannot everything from within the
federal government
we'd like to see the error
cooperative venture with my campus was
put in the states
local control local operation of cost
the federal government only coming into
a fortnight
of playing a small part of frost
as a republican leader leader organs in
the senate
you don't know of any uh...
tendency or your desire on the part of
the republican
to repeal any of the major uh... i don't
know if this makes it more pertaining to
any other
all right that there may be from changes
the that would be found in the right
direction but
bowman a torpedo anybody
uh... found there are some people
employed and it would be two words
state-controlled leading to educate
people with the senator is a final
question sir
since you are sickness and in the senate
races and her that you referred back to
you too
big states and which
you think the republicans have the best
chance to gain seats in the senate this
year
i think we have a mexican counterfeiting
to three thousand america
uh... played in in now
mollen
a seat in michigan
street in wyoming
proceed in new mexico
uh... same west virginia
mhm seat in kentucky
maybe some others and uh... arizona
uh... we have a
over a fighting chance in arizona
and manicure believes that there is an
excellent chance and cooler i can see
that where we could capture the senate
by uh... eh
to trail for goldman
western certain that our viewers that
very much appreciate these views from
united thank you for being with us
the editorial board for the position of
the wrong thing in common folk art
mister william bradford gillian and
mister kyle here
our distinguished guests what they are
both out of prison
united states senate up on your lap
logging watches appealed to a particular
people
and women of distinction who look
for public appearance
and performance
as well as and other things that they
thought
but from what we wrote also appeal to
you
for excellence
ample evidence
ballgame is really wanted mister
the winds and morals background prizes
twenty eight gold medal award
for accuracy and on the market that one
profit on it from the world's great
government observer
and i won't be much
discriminating men and women find fault
with finish in performance
and remember if you would say
seventy one fifty or more for a while
you're paying the price of alone gene
and you should insist on getting
involved it
for throughout the world
no i'm in a model option means so much
laundry
the world's most powerful
premium product of the lawn jane what
norwalk ca
since eighteen fifty six
maker bought those are the highest debt
we invite you to join us every monday
wednesday and friday evening at the same
time
for the wrong thing in common
a television journal of the important
thing for the layout
broadcast on the are all gone green
the world's most all night long
and whatnot distinguished companion for
the world on and on the
if in fact not
the miami herald that long to a man with
a lot
enthoven service from costa rica
by more than four thousand leading
killer
proudly to play with them
agent rainfall on jane with no out
leave
almost armored off
you
on june watches that one can work with
grand prizes forty eight gold medals and
laura's for accuracy than any other time
argue the world court on our part made
and guaranteed by the arguing with my
laptop
plan for the aren't being honored
television journal of the implementation
of the hour
haha you every monday wednesday and
friday
a presentation about our game what about
what happened
later on lunging the world's most
armored walk
and what
distinguished companion to the world on
advancing
good evening
allah co-editors for this edition of the
laundry in common school far
mister william bradford jewelry editor
of the american mercury
mr edgar baker managing editor of
time-life international
our distinguished guest for this evening
is the honorable styles bridges
united state senator from new hampshire
the opinions expressed are necessarily
those of the speakers
so it's a bit easier because it had a
long and distinguished career in the
senate
and tonight i promise to our audience is
tremendously interested
and all that there are over the
president's seizure of the steel mills
i'm sure that we'd like your opinions
tonight sir
this is an unprecedented action on the
part of the president said
and that you only
i've been in the son of sam sixteen
years
by wednesday that
to there has been a great here
revulsion from the country
on this
in the last few days and many issues
since i've been in the sand except
the core packing schema president
rumsfeld
and the removal of general douglas
macarthur
by uh... president truman
i think going to both of those issues
uh...
created a greater
her come back from the country
but suddenly
next to a vote to issues the rescission
of the steel mills from this
unprecedented action
comes next do you think that the public
is getting manure alice to you sir i've
heard they are becoming around as they
review of the consequences and the full
reading of the city and and do you think
it was there as a as a veteran of the
senate
do you feel that any grade
constitutional issue is involved that
there is just for kate and for the
people's being arouse ideal
now i'll tell you why mr hill
because all of the four we've had
private property seized by the president
of the united states before
in various places all those before
that's been based upon some statutory
fark
uh... some basis of law
this is the first time
the president has ever tracked in such a
step
when we haven't had done the statute
books
a pacific war lychee attributed his
action to you're telling either
so what you're doing our audience that
that in your opinion there is no
respected on the books now that would
justify the president's agar damaged
well senator one of the practical
alternative wearable whether
alternatives lazar another course to
present to the following
yes who prevented a damaging staged a
certainly could have uh... invoke the
provisions of the top top react but
uh... you know mr baker
he has solar
few of the top top reactors are prepping
moret
for a period of years that i suppose he
uh...
hesitated to use that miss simpson's but
he could invoke the top pot react
which would have brought on a wait for
the study of eighty day
and then he could attack misstep by
asking the attorney general united
states
the brain and junction the courts
against a strike
and then the costly top five reacted and
the
uh... we have all the legislation which
would provide for in coming to congress
barrier for recourse action
well senator now with the president has
in effect fast ball back to congress by
sending
his message which some people have been
interpreted as a confession of arab
uh... united concedes that the final
decision does rests with the congress
what what action would you expect to
have to be forthcoming from capitol hill
i think that care
uh... thursday should be examined very
carefully
uh... by the judiciary committee of the
senate
which is very uh... along to the
committee of the senate most certainly
is a local constitutional
approach
and arab reaction that's occurred in the
senate would cheer her dressing room the
papers tonight
about the labor committee of the senate
going to have no holding hearings are
dealing with something
which is outside a ship issues involved
in the strike our side issue
the fundamental basic issue
as the president of the united states
assuming dictatorial powers in my
judgment unseating a gradient your bank
said that the prosecution issue is
overriding it must be decided first at
least
uh... before we decide that who's right
and who's wrong in the labor
consequences of course what may happen
in a way to the surgeon on these
incidentally fumes
what you have a
uh... the wages
uh... they always do you shop for the
dole shop and so on in the uh... that's
right
and i have a very different issue would
be
with the story may live radiation was
still remaining uh... they acknowledge
mister jordan mr baker of the president
of the united states conceded the steel
mills
uh... he can also by the same terry sees
cattle on the farms in the ranch is you
can see is the poultry in the focus is
on the farm
he didn't uh...
three private property anywhere because
if you remember when he took the stand
uh... and issued this audit
he said i am
uh... taking this stand by virtue of my
authority
a basket in me by the constitution and
the laws of the united states and as
part of the united states and commander
themselves
he didn't list anne cooper said before
and a definite law and over again will
broad statement which he made which
uh... is over
riding issue so you're saying sir that
this is not
enola gay america
though versus a labor of management
versus labor controversy it is very
definitely more than that
uh... when uh... for instance
the produce a used the support of the
coal mine
para during the war he sees them under a
definite statue which one of the smith
calmly act
when you say if the railroad he saved
them under the railroad act of nineteen
sixty
and uh... so when the story of the
montgomery ward plan
uh... easy is it
uh... based upon me
construction actual call
an hour
uh... we have not always a respectable
we have no one was that so you can still
meet on inherent powers
as commander in chief of the army navy
and to be constructed
uh...
nest a biker mice to kill anybody should
have done instead accordingly
secondary commas
in charge of the steel mills at p_s_ two
american energy for the army navy ship
website very defensive gross allahabad
in this case an eternity even in the
very very few days which elapsed between
the time of the decision union strike
the president's action we lost a half
million tons of steel
comparison was based on a very practical
very practical situation a practical
threat
uh... to the national defense effort
and and he cited his inherent powers
which i believe the courts and in a
number of occasions in the past in
different situations help with the are
inherent dollars
uh... of the presidency
what are your feeling are there no
powers the president can use in a
situation of of this nature with the
national defense may be endangered joi
couldn't vocal we have more of the top
top react as i said eighty days waiting
period he could have
the
vied for the attorney general of the
brain
injunctions in the courts
mood at the separately says that he can
make a
a report to congress and uh... for
action by the congress and ask
uh... that no started with plenty of
things for him to do
well certain at this is a political year
and so what are the political
implications here specifically
uh... as a practical politician do you
think that this was smart
politics for the president
well i i don't know i think uh...
somewhat question of the president was
going to run again to be done it but
uh...
uh... he's apparently not a candidate
uh... may i point out also use handicap
for the fact that he's conducted this
section of london war in korea
he says this is a preset
i think we're in a war in korea
the program has avoided that issue and
joe
he couldn't really talk to the fact that
way or another
and a great uh... war he said
had to and
assume some police lecture are somewhat
on no
well now sir where do you think this
this business
it is a isn't overriding issue i mean do
you think that the american public
should be gravely concerned in short is
this a step along the road toward a
possible dictatorship if you have any
serious yes i don't believe that there
were on the road to dictatorship here
yet but i'm saying that we had
we could be starting on the road no
princeton's
and all of these socialistic country
where we are
trade-up socialism miller
and so on there's no socialist
country that has achieved by order of
the
ruling power
uh... mailings for instance when they go
to maximize the
steel mills and uh...
uh... great britain they perceive martin
another manner according to the law or
the land
you're saying that not even in the
socialistic country says they've been so
aggressive in action on the flyer you
have to get into the dictatorship
dollars
where that pair
uh... you know the communists will
assist us underground where you see
examples of this
would you say that this is a step toward
possible nationalization of the steel
industry and sudbury eset dot hope not
but it could be final power web address
with the fact that it should address
mister baker
where the call
and if we had independent free corpses i
hope we have in some instances certainly
it might be in the courts
butter in a in any case the final result
would be the banking
according to our constitution of the
legislative against the executive
process as we understand it is that i
fight between the congress and the
president and we very much thank you for
being with us tonight
the editorial board for this edition of
the laundry and promised go for it
mister william bradford theory
and mr edgar baker
our distinguished guests with the
honorable styles bridges
united state senator from new hampshire
one of the virtues of our free
enterprise system
is the benefits to the public mean
better quality and lower prices which
spring from free and open competition
certainly the stimulus of competition
has resulted in ever finer and finer on
gene watches
and it was in free and open competition
that long dream became the in fact
the world's most armored walks
honored for excellence in elegance
bike then world's fair grand prizes
twenty-eight gold medal awards
honored for accuracy by innumerable
prizes
and bulletins from the great government
observatories
honored for honesty and sports a_b_a_
shin explorations
falsify with the quality and true
investment value
long gene watchers have become first
of discriminating men and women in every
country of the free world
so if you wish to purchase a very fine
watch
either for yourself or as a gift
or a calming graduation
or an anniversary for any important
occasion
look for the troop quality in the walk
to body and york choice will be
launching
the world's most on that one
premio product of the launching witten
or watch company
since eighteen fifty six
maker of waters of the highest karen
david ross
speaking for your host frank not
inviting you to join us every monday
when day on friday evening
at the same time
for the long gene comical
a television journalist important
includes the payoff
broadcast on behalf of laundry
the world's most armor walk
and whitmore distinguished companion
for the world are not laundry
golden service
from coast to coast
by more than four thousand leading to a
minute
who proudly display of the emblem
agency paul long-chain with norwalk
time for the plunging
television journal of the important
issues of the aisle
partial you every monday wednesday and
friday
presentation of the laundry list of all
what happened
later on
lodging world's most holocaust
and lifting off distinguished companion
to the world honored laundry
good evening
this is ninety nine
may i introduce our color that goes for
this edition of the laundry in prosto
mister william bradford u_n_ editor of
the american worker m
and most of them i have
editor of the freemen and contributing
editor of newsweek magazine
our distinguished guests was the main
is the honorable ourselves bana united
state senator from utah
the opinions expressed
aren't necessarily those of the speakers
the senator bennett you've makes a
vigorous speeches lately about the
presidency the steel industry
how wonderful and ask you what you think
the principal factor that's easier now
likely to be
financially
long-range implications and some that
are affecting us already
i think the principal long-range
implication
will be felt in the continuing study of
the american people of the powers of the
president we're concerned again
about uh... whether there are any
limitations on the powers of the
president
what do you think will be done about
that
cases reported to have
diet decision
and i think if the supreme court
should not do it
we may expect before preamp
to see it proposed amendment to the
constitution
which might spell out in the
constitution interpretation given by
judge pack
you're saying you're telling our
audience on that day
that in the event the supreme court does
not sustain jets
that do you think that there is that
congress within the camp
to make it sprang this decision to write
it into the constitution is that correct
sir
and i think that will happen every
happiness this session of congress which
has a short
life ahead of it for whether that might
be postponed until nineteen fifty eight
as a member of congress and you think
that
said
congress must soon
uh... in effect there specifically
defiantly the inherent power to the
president
congress has the power and amend the
constitution
and the only power to initiate that but
i didn't read the states have a
concurrent power
but i think uh... congressman exercise
that pat what you think they have the
intention you think that's the sentiment
of congress of the present time that
if the supreme court fails to sustain
judge hides decision
that immediately congressman do
something of historic
i think your food
matter were up for a vote tomorrow
both houses
would act that way overwhelming we will
have any effect on labor legislation
if anything
yes i i'm not sure how many of the
effect will be
because of course the president has the
taft hartley law he hadn't used it in
this particular case and there many of
us in congress who feel that we
shouldn't have any new labor legislation
situation exists until after the
president has used taft-hartley
for the long run
i would expect
some new labor legislation to grow out
of his
expiry well along what lines
would be a limitation of the right to
strike is that one of the lines of the
nineteen eighty
seizure experience
has shown that there is a limitation of
the right to strike even the union
agrees that it will not strike against
the government
and judge pirro goldsboro in nineteen
forty eight indicated
with the court's take the position
labor may not strike against the
ultimate interests of the nation even
though the government isn't involved
and that there be any effort to restrain
industry-wide unions are from try to
prevent the growth of these enormous
industry-wide i think that's a
possibility
i was interested to discover that when
the sherman
law was passed in eighteen ninety unions
were included as well as individuals and
corporations specifically included yes
and they have since escape by it
well by implication and via direct
amending legislation for one thing
uh... immunized so to speak of the
clayton
electorate and uh... and revision
morris regarding acting
outback may be restored
answer to you say that there is deep
concern in the senate over this
constitutional issue
do you believe that the american public
is also deeply concerned
and i wish there were more deeply
concerned
and uh... i have a feeling
this may have introduced a new issues in
the forthcoming campaign
and i hope the republicans will do what
they can do
create a more uis great concern you say
that you wish they were more deeply
concerned actually you have you heard
from the public uh... from your mail and
otherwise to be rather apathetic it
denied
has precios if
the public are more concerned about the
immediate effects
strike and the seizure and the
implications of the price
control problem
and uh... they're not aware of the
fundamental constitutional problem there
as a practical
politicians there why do you think
that the american public
is not greatly concerns over this
constitutional issue which you regard is
so important
twelve in the first place
many americans feel that all
constitutional problems were settled
a hundred and fifty years ago in this
week
past the point for a fundamental
problems have to be clean
resulted
well there's a difference doesn't seem
to be reflected in the press you think
that there's a gap between the protest
in the press the present
and the feelings of people
active suppressed or or call me
came out uh... in opposition to the
president's plan gives me hope that in
the months ahead it's attitude
we'll actually be reflected in the
public opinion i'd like to ask what they
have selected this action will be on the
control powers on the extension of the
control powers and the kind of control
powers if you think gave people in
congress and let the president had
and all the facts are already have it
so far as the senate is concerned
the senate banking and currency
committee
has completed its work on the
want to extend the president's power
it looked back
quickly finished with its work when the
steel seizure half and then it stopped
dead
and since then it has gone back and
completely revised its proposed law in
these interesting respect
originally they were to be extent of the
year
now it's eight months
originally they didn't do very much to
the wage stabilization board
now as a result of this experience they
practically re
well-off acting wage stabilization
borden take away from
all the powers that claimed in this
particular decision
so they would still have a way
stabilization born
that would be fixing wages while they
would be a price control of fixing
prices and neither of them would pay
much attention to what the other was
doing it seems to be that situation
present without the continued on and i
was like i would imagine she will become
more important
maybe it would have been carried to the
question is
that wages are within the stabilization
have nothing to do with union shopper
fringe benefits
and its
membership will be made up of public
members only and does it have to be
confirmed by the senate
so we have our hands on the wage they
decided uh...
i do you come from the very intersting
stated yourself
uh... your governor governor lee has
attracted a great deal of attention then
uh...
you have a senator that's up for
reelection this year
so i'm sure the relatives would like to
a if u expression try me on the
political scene
in the mountains states
now has the uh... utah delegation uh...
to the republican national convention
been selected
that was selected homemade
i can't remember the day but it was like
a couple weeks ago in salt lake and
it is
one hundred percent
for senator tech fourteen dog
and what's a situation generally in the
mountain states in the republican party
senator taft will have
the great majority of the delegates from
the mountain states there have been one
or two
places where
and eisenhower delegate arteries are
slipping
overwhelmingly it's overwhelmingly that
country
are you personally supporting such a
test
harry have announced my position that
way and do it
i'm happy that my state supported me
and and census you have
uh... says the governor governor lee is
up for reelection and also senator what
consumers
would you get a verdict for our audience
how utah is likely to go in nineteen
fifty two
sex is the uh...
attitude in utah is that there as
everywhere else there's a great unrest a
great feeling that this is time for
change
and i'm sure it's going to sweet bowl
senator walk-ins and governor lee back
into office together with many other
republican nominate
what do you think the effect is going to
be on the election of ms truman stand on
seizure
hasn't enough that carried his party
pretty far over the last with these
statements by vice president barkley and
secretary told on and so on what's going
to be the effect on the nomination
well i think
kidneys made it very difficult for the
middle of the royal democrats for the
jefferson jeffersonian democrats
to stay with the democratic
not only with him as an individual but
with the party
kathy says he's going to match
do you think that is selected and the
democratic party this year will have a a
new deal around the knee and that they
will run on a own on the new deal
platform in the steady a platform that
the president
is insisting upon
i think there is every every evidence
that that will happen
the only possible
candidate that can save him from that is
senator russell
and i've got that he's got
power enough to get the nomination
you don't think that it's likely that
a candidate this nominated by both
parties
i'd certainly amount in favor of the
one-party system
and i hope the republicans don't
contribute to it
and there
and and you also think that you'd they
would be best for the country
if there is a we'll debate
and a few
erased between a vw dealer for delay
and they have a conservative republican
i think the american people have been
wanting that
for twenty years and i hope we have here
wisdom to give it to us
and as a final question sir since you
come from a great moment state of utah
moments of the known to be conservative
in the past
uh... is the state leading uh... toward
uh... conservatives are now do you think
wal-mart election would indicate a
movement in that direction and i think
the nineteen fifty three actions will
ferret out
as they say well thank you very much for
being with us tonight
the editorial board for this edition
not but all jane prosto flaws
mister william bradford chile
and mr
henry has worked
our distinguished guests closely on the
boat was stepped up
united states senate uh... from utah
it seems like a nice idea
on the wedding day the pride in
give watches
if you're planning a wedding you might
be glad to know that
recognizing the social accepted
plunging has produced an exciting series
of duets
exquisite launching martyrs and matching
style
each pricewatch
domenico replica of the groom as well
exchanging rocket is likewise a growing
trust between husbands and wives for
anniversary gift
and for any differently shinde no other
name on a watched means so much
showers laundry
the world's most are blocked
the only watch in history
to wind down
world's fair grand prizes
twenty-eight gold medals
and so many honest or accuracy from the
world's observatories
and yes you may find a bill
or client probably give bob launching
watch
for as little as seventy one fifty
seen long gene duet
another beautiful on g mobsters sort of
way
by authorized to other agency
long jane the world's most on iraq
premium product of the long jama na
watch company
since eighteen sixty six
maker of watches of the highest yeah
we invited to join us every monday and
wednesday and friday evening at the same
time
the logging promise co
a television journal of the important
issues of the hour
broadcast on the top all long jane
the world's mohammed walked
and working on a distinguished companion
world all night long journey
this is frank night
reminding you about launching
and withdraw watches
also
from coast to coast
by more than
proudly display of december
agency
all daunting but not locked
time for the something promised
television journal of the important
cases of the opt
talk show you every monday wednesday and
friday presentation of the laundry with
robot health
later on
launching the world's most common law
and lifting off distinguished companion
to the world on it on g
good evening
this is fright night
matter and reduced auto editors for this
edition of the mounting prosto
mister william bradford chile
editor of the american record
and mister james h_ r_ problem
former united states minnesota
our distinguished guests for the
big-name is the although william f_
buckley
united states and the fare from
connecticut
the opinions expressed unnecessarily
those of the speaker
senator then it's a pleasure to have you
with us a nicer on the crime itself
i can heal
for our for our viewers would you
identify yourself politically are you a
new dealer a supporter of the president
said
general i'm a very consistent supporter
of the press that they are
differ with him and his advisors in
certain major ways
i have with senator paul toughest fight
there could be a part of the most
administrations and do to get our budget
into balance
to cut back on expenditures
i have fought subsidies to uh...
agriculture feature the substance of
others subsidies
the roughly speaking and certainly on
the foreign policy i would describe
myself as a supporter of the president's
your onslaught of sound money and new
deal again is that correct
i like to think about stuff that they
are those who are thrown off the views
that differ they should apply it to me
you believe that having a balanced
budget in other words senators that
right
thought that was that i have joined
together in recommending not only have
cut that seven-and-a-half
billion dollars out of the budget mister
cromwell but in trying to close up
a tax loopholes maybe to catch them rich
fellows like uh... the crab apples
to pick up an articulate a half billion
dollars to bring the cash budget into
balance at about ten billion dollars
would do it i'm sure that your is it
like a prediction from you sir as to
whether you think the budget is likely
to be balanced
this year sisterhood is not a chance in
norway
it's going to be out of balance five
billion
in a presidential election year you'll
never get the congress to pass the tax
bill which the president recommended
which i would be four
and you're never going to get
the congress to make these cuts in
appropriations bills because the
pressures of too many people
uh... involved i have to spend the money
you remember that cindy four other guys
don't you hold up a joke and into a
young congressman by sun never vote
a for a tax bill or against it
appropriately should be ok if you go out
that applies that particular advising
the for in an election year isolation
now sir i believe that you have ah...
taken a rather strong position on the
civil rights program
and our jurors are very much interested
in uh... tonight because
uh... general eisenhower this week
took a very firm stand against it
federal civil rights program yes now
what what is your position on civil
rights
cooperative marginalized and are now
have respect for his judgment that all
different him a lot different sharply
on this particular question civil rights
uh... mister who is a is a problem for
all the people not a problem
state-by-state
and the reason it's a problem for all
the people is that our failure in the
field of civil rights in power failure
in the field of our racial relations
are doing justice to our neeku negro
group another racial minorities
stuff out of communist all over the
world
thrown back at us and indeed it's the
most damaging of all the communist
propaganda
we forget that two-thirds of the peoples
of the world have colored skin
and pay after gaining a communist
propaganda hammers and a bit
uh... mines of these people
uh... that we discriminate within just
we don't live up to our democratic
placements
and that's too important to let
mississippi and alabama decide that's a
problem for all the american people
producing share senator that it's
possible to
all of these days
krishna fooled by legislation
not if it
uh... it's a long slow educational
process mister cromwell but
as with all the education you stronger
pack in front of you
we have for civil rights legislation up
in the state of connecticut
it doesn't mean that there is the stuff
of discrimination week redirect can't
get rid of it
merely by passing laws
but when the people of the states a
ticket
we stand against
if that gets the policy at the state
uh... we are going to set up by the
courts and commissions
uh... we have a case in the state right
fell against a labor union for refusing
to permit negroes to join
and it's the first case of its kind in
the country
and it's a fine thing for the people of
our state to get the education that's
involved in that case when i'd like to
see the abuse that the american people
not have before them on this
general eisenhower i believe he's taken
a rare the firm stand against federal
action in the civil rights matter
absolutely i read his administrator
nolte there no qualifying clauses that
he's he simply against it
uh... senator taft has certain
qualifying poses uh...
senate if you fall bird who's been on
this program
now if you had believe sir are almost
completely on the other side from from
general eisenhower if you believe in
federal action i'm not so either with
any southern delegates i'm not a
candidate for the presidency
fell out of my long experience in uh...
foreign policy mister
who we are represented the united states
of aid international conferences as a
delegate of this country
i've talked to the people of
other countries who sent delegates there
and this is jocelyn elders all the time
and not only by the rush
naturally
by the indians by others
i told on the floor of the senate uh...
last ah... martha is putting a mccarran
immigration bill the study of nurses
the story of missus clinton the meeting
in japan in nineteen thirty seven
we saw the proc
flags break out all over japan
it was the anniversary of our exclusion
act on receptivity twelve cents of the
people of japan not one of you is fifty
come into the united states
japan went in the morning
all historians agree that our exclusion
act against the japanese
i can be one of the major factors that
led to the attack on pearl harbor so i
give that is a quick illustration to
show how important
uh... actions in this field is from the
standpoint of all our people so if you
are a member of the senate next year
uh... he had not yet when you're a
member of the must be accompanied
applies your constituents can depend on
you to try to overcome the traditional
southern opposition to uh...
to federal legislation in this field
sisterhood connecticut secre literate
state that they didn't know that i agree
with you i would never chance to go back
to the senate
senator would like a few words you use
your own this uh...
on your activities and they have mutual
security program the money that we are
sending to europe
now i believe if you have uh...
have been the responsible for an
amendment to that program not just what
are you trying to do with that amendment
so i'll try to combat communism in
europe and the strength in the hands of
our administrative officers
who are fighting communism of course the
basic purpose of the mutual security act
is to fight communism and to prepare
ourselves to fight communism if we come
throws open uh... outbreak of hostility
and specifically how will your
how will your program health in combat
in communism in europe for my president
that mattel's mister harriman and his
associates the administrators of this
act
to spend these vast sums of money to six
billion four hundred million dollar
under discussion
insects raises to discourage the
great european monopolies and cartels
furniture
hold back production and hamstring
uh... productivity which is the very
thing we're trying to encourage
and in the second place to discourage
the communist labor unions and to
encourage the development of the kind of
free labor unions really fighting for
the welfare of the workers of the time
we have here in the united states
senator increasing prepare great many
people don't realize the difference
between the way business is conducted
here in the united states to actually
run and the way it's conducted in europe
i wonder if you would think it was a
little uh...
discussion about uh... the difference
between competitive business in the
united states and monopoly business or
cocktail business
has returned in europe
throughout the bait you put your finger
mister kahwar right on the basic
difference
the basic difference uh...
and attitudes of the american people
accords right back at two eighteen
ninety when we passed the sherman
antitrust act
there isn't any antitrust legislation in
europe it all
our laws out
mr jeffery crop there's a lot of the
columnist but the thing wonderfully
ready once said
we put a man in the house of lords in
england for the very thing in the united
states for which you put in
innocence in penitentiary
carlos a
you can't combine and mary's monopolized
fixed markets fixed prices
control production
failed to put in new machinery
and eliminate competition
all over europe trip
european businessman is changing exactly
the opposite viewpoints
and every european country iran in a
business sense abiding the cartels and
the monopoly what do you think the
chances are of a changing the european
point of view on that changing the
europe and businessman witnesses then it
changed as you point out that makes the
gap between the european in the business
communities
psychologically in american business
community much greater the atlantic
ocean
it will take two years
oddly enough the best chance right now i
think c germany
center then take a break it up in
germany they sell for breaking it up
throughout much of the really
interesting
audience of course i understand that you
are up for reelection in connecticut
and quite frankly i believe the
republicans think that they have a
chance to win your seat this year israel
uh... now what was pretty that now you
are expected area and vigorous campaign
uh... assume in connecticut
it's certainly a vigorous campaign that
mister perot because uh...
the status on compact
uh... highly literate politically
um... then feels much money spent in
connecticut by the republicans
in the expectation that i think he will
not be are vulnerable sectors who can't
be successfully dislodged
i don't like that
topic that is that if the thought of it
perhaps you'll be sure that was there
for me
now i a m
physician shirt you take
nationally in mid-may inmates
race between the democrats and
republicans
if you endorsed any anything any
candidate for the presidency
away in connecticut have endorsed my
senior colleague on the plan
i believe that the uh... democrats there
too much sense
uh... tomorrow morning to campus groups
with whom we can't wait
uh... you know uh...
hahaha
uh... i live therefore predict a
democratic victory though i i agree with
you
there are some democratic candidates
now in the field with whom we can't win
center so there is a tie-up between the
candidates at the anticipated victoria
that on the first to admit
i'm sure that i have here is very much
appreciate your views tonight show and
thank you for being with all
congratulate you on the quality of these
programs
the editorial board for this edition of
the mounting promised those laws
mister william bradford chile and mister
james h_ r_ cromwell
our distinguished guests closely on over
with him at that time
united state senator from connecticut
confronting the manufacturer of an
article of extreme position
such as a launching
to deliver to hit the pendulum
in the same perfect condition
in which it leaves the factory
now for that reason building watchers
have always been distributed directly
from the factory through limited number
of joy
qualified knowledge
and experience to handle boxes
of monty growth
these jurors are authorized long gene
with north to imitate
and in this way your show
ethanol jing watch which would live is
aware the representative of the only
watch in history to end to end welfare
grand prizes
twenty eight gold medals and highest
honors for accuracy from the leading
government observatories of the world
till the next
fueled by a lot
for yourself
or for an important to get the patient
the laundry in the world's most common
law
sold under our factory guarantee away
after all thrived on gene with knowledge
or agency
throughout the world know what the name
on a watch
means so much as long as being the
world's most common law
premium product for the long game but
not what happened
since eighteen sixty six
maker of watches all of the higher
we invite you to join us every monday
wednesday and friday evening at the same
time
for the logging problem
television journal of the important
business of the hour
broadcast on the top of laundry in the
world's most on it locked
and with nor distinguished companion for
the world on a donkey
this is pragmatic
reminding you that long remembered
volatile
are sold and service
coast to coast
by more than four thousand leading
dilemma
who proudly displayed as amber
agency logon team with norwalk
meeting time for the laundry
television journal of the implementation
of the house
partial you every monday wednesday and
friday
presentation of the laundry mclaughlin
company
later on
long-chain the world's most on it a lot
and what
distinguished companion to the world all
night long gene
good evening
this is david rocks
tonight the launching promised school
turns away from the man-made problems of
the world
to an examination of spiritual values
a subject in keeping with the holiday
season
to help you find the truth
father john shea
c_s_ speed editor of catholic world
reverend dr william rosenblum
rabbi temple israel of the city of new
york
reverend dr robert j mccracken
pastor of riverside church
father charles holographic saint john's
church in the village
our moderator is mister william bradford
leary
the
promised group yourself now satisfied
all of the material requirements for
christmas
and tonight we'd like to
explore some of their spiritual yearning
and now up on the grant
if our average viewer tonight for their
stories
spiritual gift for christmas what gives
do you think would be hard to miss
i think that men this year we are
looking for security
a security which is based on upon
material factors
but the security which is based upon god
the creator
was the ultimate security from him
i think men want
a peace that can only be found
as exemplified in the season and the
christ child in the manger
and piece of the price
reconcile and thirdly i think men are
looking for moral forty-two and stamina
in a time when men are not recognizing
always moral values
soooooo security troops in morro stamina
now were rabbi rosenbloom
has been said that this is a nervous
ajun aspirin age and uh... beijing
non-serb worked with you
well for two hour beavers
and some
from these tensions at that time
let's not do what i a also her but i
think is analyzing a dramatist wrote
taneja heartache and headache a great
many tensions
in all areas and the phrase asked for an
aids is a very
angeles eloquent description on the
negative side
i believe is a positive awareness about
the station
that people generally want to do
something about
is an aspiring it is part of the
american slang deals
and i think our presence here tonight
exemplifies what the formula would be
flown to improve conditions
because the religions of the world we
represent some of them
having that keeping
spiritual idealism on values
that will make for peace in the from the
world
and i think if we can get together
no more constructive program i believe
that's one of the great hopes for the
future
a public hearing
the infant christ has been cool
a symbol of weakness
and now in these days of means to meet
the challenges of our time
do you think that we needed to move
twelve twelve with the infant christ is
lord
a symbol of human weakness
about the same time i believe that uh...
he is a symbol of uh... divine power
are not only divine physical or a firmly
believe that it's gonna be created this
from the moon stars of
asbestos townsend says that
the swings were like a trend that has at
its worst
but uh... more importantly he is a
professor of infinite mohawk
and i do firmly believe that uh...
uh... his city dixon's law giver must be
old buddy
and any ruler
roulette users who violate the natural
law established by god must go down to
destruction
leprosy price contributed to the concept
of human dignity
vault soulful and
p constantly emphasized the dignity of
the human person means teachings
being consulted with uh...
video-harp scoring might say the skull
on the streets of review of jerusalem
balked at the same time he shortly
reference
or for the souls of those persons
and i think that uh...
that their dignity as fathers in his
teaching has come down to austin has
been operated in the magnet caught in
the bill of rights
but more importantly i'd say that the
fact of the incarnation
has uh... given western thinking
anne and awareness
of the dignity of man and the fact
two adult children chronic himself a
newman a jury
the uh... became one of us in order that
we might be adopted into the family of
god
and i think that uh... the fact of the
incarnation the fact of the broke the
ball and christmas
has ah...
given to uh... what's important for you
plo awareness
of the dignity of human person
and not this christmas and there's a
christmas
nineteen fifty two prabhu
for the future wall we think it does lol
hope provided we have humility
netsolmail someone said that arrogance
is the key people of art and that's very
true
and i think there's no surprise to uh...
the yield on home and adoration of the
incident
uh... doctor mccracken
most of us are familiar with professor
to engage
the u_n_
of the human procession
creeping up the mountain side rather
laboriously
and their periods in human history when
the perception seems to make progress
and other periods when it seems to be in
confusion and retreat
now how do you feel soon christmas
nineteen fifty two do you think that we
are they are perception at this plant is
making progress so that perhaps we are
so confused maybe in retreat
i know mister show you how i would like
to feel i would like to think that we
were making distinct
hariharan disposed to
avoid generalize issues because
while twenty certainly made when i had a
professor of history who
use to st louis never generalize
seeing it making a generalization
at the same time i i think it's an
contest the bluebird
that things are going from bad to worse
and the lives
criminal minded or
they fight club created
in nineteen fourteen when war broke out
lights are going out all over europe
yet try on christmas eve nineteen fifty
two i'm not without hope
costs at all
christianity is an optimistic religion
founded on uh...
provisionally pessimistic view man
exclaim and realizes his predicament
feels neat
and except their point of course the
christmas
particularly significant inasmuch
as it means that man doesn't lift a work
of his themselves which will not
only friends
she represented here
the principal judeo-christian please
is it true that today's date
on alerted
great danger that time
and the danger of the all-powerful state
the danger of communism
on the the the only thing that is the
principled intervention
i would say that there's a deepening
understanding of the on that
hopefully uh... restaurant
of the problem presented to us by soviet
communism bull
i would they want to read
deeply conscious to problems closer to
home
and of the danger of home so
decadence from within
point i might add that twenty brings out
uh... pomegranate
do you feel hopeful as an individual for
the human perception in nineteen fifty
two thank you very much
because i think that
the realization that
faces ultimately the the basis of
seeking for security and
peace and most eminent
that many awakening
is going to have a profound effect upon
oversight
in his words i have because i think men
are realizing now
it isn't waiting
holdings in june for us to have hope
for free government there and i wouldn't
is it necessary for us to have must be
inhale fades and all in order to support
free government
i think well i think we have seen that
there is no freedom
because every single dictator what we
have in the past
those in recent years and those are in
palma
some of the first things they tried to
do my fourth in between
seceded states out of the lives of
people
and i think you find in the democratic
countries like iran
while there are some tensions and
difficulties and disappointment
somewhere on the great situation
so there's always the swelling up off
the face of god
their faith and light puzzle to real
purpose and i think they simply go
together bothers her and you mentioned
the great
documents magnetron earn declaration
isn't noble work shit from command of
man
do you think that those could have
sprung only from and
well very definitely
when the very
home to upload
concise religious
principles
and is that you did the when the dreaded
totalitarianism his over all of us
is it true that all totalitarian
governments problem sounds must first
destroyed even attempt to destroy if any
dot mccracken is that
from relative high idle
no destroy she's about to leave this all
the states in the media
the leader of principle
chastened involved seems to go
but do you think uh... or whether you
think you know post-soviet
well the totalitarian concept
even believe in the all-powerful state
was not run room here it is a uh... of
christianity christians
the idea that the individual man
considered himself important bloodline
written to be free
homeowner
enemy the outlook
for nineteen fifty three
uh... do all of you believe that uh...
that there is a
any any realization on the part of the
american people have a need for
morphing into a proper balance between
thinking reasoning
financial thank you liane
blossoming dogs in churches in their way
of life
and returns home to the idea is
installed anything to perhaps more more
americans will will go to church for
instance in the next twenty-four hours
ended last year
well certainly the tightening of the
religious element in the christmas
celebrations this year
was that
than women throughout europe appreciate
these expressions from you and thank you
very much for being with us
very distinguished guests all belong to
impose corpus evening world copper john
feur m
c_ s_p_ editor of the catholic world
reverend dr william rosenbloom rabbi of
temple israel of the city of new york
reverend dr robert j mccracken
pastor of riverside church
product charles hologram
of saint john's church in the village
them operator for the special holiday
programme
was mister william bradford hwy
they problem out but i think that gift
of great preppy
profound one-day randhir trio ismael
properly solve for the long email
throughout the world no other name on a
lot
characters like that the fed
long jeans
the world's most on it well
manuel program prizes and for the eight
gold medals for excellence and elegant
and hired followed for accuracy probably
teamed up with the burgers as i recall
being in fact the world's most all night
long
now whenever you need to prevent the
gift of great prestige for about uh...
for an anniversary for an important
occasion remember the fact
and remember to
thank you made by admiral walk by and
probably have
alone being dropped
for as little as seventy one fifty
logging in the world's most powerful
premium product of the wrongdoing but
not what company
since eighteen fifty six
maker of what uh... rob and gary
we invited to join us every monday
wednesday and friday evening
at that same time for the long being
pumped
a television journal of the important
paper that we are
broadcast on behalf of logging in the
world's most on a block
and weapon or the fingers companion for
the world are daunting
if in fact knife reminding you that long
denied but no i want to october forever
from coast to coast
by more than four thousand leading
killer
probably the greater than
agent report on greenwood norwalk
don junkie thomas
a television journal of the important
issues of the uh... brought to you every
monday wednesday and friday
presentation oven on jane what's not
watch company
maker of plunging the world's most on a
block
and whatnot distinguished companion to
the world ahmed laundry
good evening that the strike that
may i introduce our collateral for this
edition of the monthly incomes co
larry let's uh... from the c_b_s_
television news dot
and august texture chief editorial
writer for the new york herald tribune
our distinguished guests for this
evening as sir alexander graham
governor general of hong kong
most of this is a company with the name
hong kong is
that with that british crown colony
itself
because of the korean war
and those charges that the island of
hong kong was
furnishing communist china with the
seniors of war well british and american
troops were fighting the chinese
communist on the other side in korea
but our guest tonight who is governor
all that strategic atlanta knows the
story
so i don't know how much illegal trader
was going on with the chinese communist
well
british and american troops were
actually fighting
the communists in korea
well that's where i'm saying that
would be to quote
performer american consul general in
hong kong who said coming up trickle
give substantiation of that and make
these parts
hong kong has la really carried out the
towns on the united nations embargo
on trade in strategical semi strategic
guards with china
part of the hong kong itself produces
nothing
nothing whatever
that communist china
now for all the communist china wants
from hong kong has to come from other
countries fucks
and other countries will not export to
hong kong
unless they are satisfied that those
grows up
teaching value are not going to be
passed on to come in this china
if those countries want to export to
communist china
the goods will bypass hong kong them
directly arrive hong kong because the
payoff afraid other controls and the
panel does
that hong kong imposes on such form of
illegal train
sags and they've had a large massive
uh...
of legal trade going on now between hong
kong and china homes have been greatly
reduced as a result of the circumstances
ambience of the matter is that yes in
both cases that might be a little bit of
logical look
homecoming
has as its natural trading partner
as a result of of the united nations
embargo and also on the terms and
conditions with chinese communists in
podunk trade event
with our country
the trade has dropped today considerably
on trade now has tripled since the
imposition of the embargo has dropped by
one-third which naturally has had a very
serious effect
on the economy of the culinary
and the livelihood of its people uh...
or what happened uh... so it's and it's
a untitled all its trade with china
because china is not a peace-loving
country even upset promos
now if i might uh... kicked the ball
mcentee rumors through some of my house
here
effect on hong kong on commonest child
difficult hong kong
out of the effect on hong kong would be
very serious indeed
because hong kong
is not self-supporting foodstuffs rose
in the food stamps
taking the overall picture
we get about haha food from communist
china notably
and notably fresh vegetables
and then hong kong would have to be
supplied from overseas and since the
distances are very great either from
britain or frustrated or america it
would be quite a problem
though so it ended
now the where is it
if it anytime a chinese communist let's
do it
get hong kong they could
me stop you out there
i don't know if it if you if it came to
that uh... that is really
wall
and when it's warm and we would be
appropriate
and uh... since the free world controls
the seas it would be possible and i'm
quite sure would be done to continue to
supply hong kong with all the food stuff
that is needed
to carry on the fight for freedom hong
kong was that overcome by the japanese
early in the second world war
and event that is quite correct hong
kong was okay
on how how the day
and if surrendered to the overwhelming
force of the japanese on christmas day
but we have to remember live in that
time
the japanese and control
not only of the seed but also the
apparatus today we have control growth
of the sea and of the application so you
really have a panel a defensible island
i certainly do i do not pose myself as a
military expert
i am
quoting the opinion of the highest
militia charges
uh... without mentioning any names also
in the united states
facilities nl valuable is hot dogs with
the world is a uh... naval base
is that does that outweigh its economic
importance
as the naval base i should say it's not
very great
at the moment because
from the british pond view there is the
file
and more up to date naval base and
single call which is only fifteen
hundred miles turf
fifteen hundred miles away that is not
the real importance of hong kong today
well uh... so i can do
is uh... hong kong ever threatened by
the chinese communist today to make
uh... gestures dangerous justice in your
direction
well i've got to use polite languages
charles butler
sometimes impolite noises about this but
it has not farther than that
played a little bit
making a major part of their propaganda
to educate continuing the hong kong
grinnell no that is eased off
considering they did in the early days
and they work
accusing hongkong of all sorts of uh...
crime as an annex which is amongst those
being a screwed of american imperialism
loose a little bit
what are your relations with the chinese
on the main another hostile or
new conduct business on the uh... polite
collect
correct basis or is achieved as friendly
feeling
the official relationship is mailed we
have no official relationships whatever
i would describe it
the attitude of the chinese communists
towards hong kong as one of
hostility
but mainly other passive rather than all
the naked nature
well then did you up
prove uh... of the visit of the uh...
labor
the former labor prime minister of
britain to uh... baking
penitentiary
well value-added marilyn red hot potato
uh...
himself but uh...
americana potatoes
sellout even take the tough part
i thought that visit was unfortunate
so we do that
go ahead
sister identified to change the subject
what is life like now
inside the island of hong kong
there i think a great number of refugees
of commitment
amid try their of economic conditions
depressed
is living intolerable
about take that question by staging a
backward
living is certainly tolerable and the
reserve a remarkable and degree of
confidence we are very overcrowded
and i'm show you appreciate that when i
tell you that
on the liberation of the column by the
british pacific fleet
in august nineteen forty five the
population was half a million
today it is true and a half millions
and our trade has dropped by one
at the way the people of hong kong
carry-over under such difficult
conditions i think israeli most
remarkable facilities and i take it that
most of the people in hong kong are
chinese
i'd like to ask you other a friendly to
the communist regime org
to the and sisters even
it's almost a
originator
when i see original that means nineteen
forty nine when the communists overran
for the whole of china
then they were inclined to be friendly
to the new regime
which of the communist regime they
didn't men see it in its true colors
but and they are now disillusioned
and that was well demonstrated last
october
went on the respective national days of
the communists the first of october
and of the nationalists on the tenth of
october the display of flags on the
tenth of october was tremendous greater
than i've ever seen a purple as tigar
secular come to uh... to hong kong
knowing he has not come to hong kong at
any time whatever
well so do the our ticket
that nevertheless in this uh...
flood of refugees if you had originally
they must have been some uh... chinese
communist agents
some sort of a fifth column
there is any danger that hong kong might
be entirely supported by the chinese
communists and
might wake up one morning at find us as
a prisoner
i say that the danger of that is about
mail
admitted their some agents do sleep in
but we know
would be main communist leaders are in
the car
and uh... accurate
we would if we wanted to pick them up
uh... we prefer to keep them about
ground rather than have them underground
on the net result and an unnatural
on carnival access to the free world as
well as the great britain itself
they're definitely they're definitely
well instead is a uh... the communists
in
regina
talking about increasing trade now now
that the is a seventeen eva
well they certainly are aris alright
rhonda great propaganda line
intelligent businessman one fall far
although they would like to see
legitimate trade in non embargoed goods
with china increasing what is the value
then of hong kong is again phase to get
information
from behind the so-called bamboo curtain
boyish figure
i think it's a it's it's the best of all
places for that
because i did it
nastiest
could you say
in hong kong that you can read the
temperature of the world in regard to
warranties
in asia
and you get some idea of
how the chinese feel about this
from out of that would be a good night
that i would say in the trustees all
wall are not many great
well let's wishful thinking on our are
really working hard to say
meet other is the chances of the chinese
uh... making for the war against hong
kong
against hong kong action tampa's
juncture
thank you very much is the most edited
at nite session
for three months
the opinions expressed on the daunting
com let's go for those of the speaker
the editorial board for this edition of
the lunging cosco clause burial
assailant and august extra
our distinguished guests
closer alexander graham from
governor-general of hong kong
the autorads accuracy and reliability
take on a new one the true meaning when
applied to a daunting watch
apology and watch brings priceless peace
of mind
for knows where one stands with time all
the time
for almost a century lunging has made
watches which by observatory
measurements have consistently been
equal or superior inaccuracy to the
highest achievement sab each decade
further proof is found in this fact
among the finest waters of the world
only launching watches have been honored
with ten world fairground prizes and
twenty eight filled out
yet though don't gene is one of the
finest evolve watches
there are many beautiful models for both
ladies and gentlemen for as little as
seventy one fifty
whatever the type whatever the style on
jane has made a point
filled one x two y one either three or
so
boris an important get these are facts
to remember
for total dissatisfaction that comes
from owning a mounting is above and
beyond price
laundry in the world's most on as well
the world's most on a gift
senior product of the lawn gene but know
what's happening
since eighteen sixty six
maker of watches are the highest debt
the
this is frank dot
reminding you that long gene and whatnot
watches
apostles and service from coast to coast
by more than four thousand leading to it
who proudly display this emblem
agency although i'm jeanne but not much
acknowledging what knowledge illiteracy
f most of our pets religion clock
created by the court
equus runs without finding without
electricity are delayed by variations in
the temperature of the atmosphere
at most product of the contra division
oblong came but now
anytime plod along gene promising
a television journal of the important
issues of the art
promptly elaborate monday wednesday and
friday
presentation of the laundry and whatnot
watch government
maker of laundry the world's most on a
block
and whatnot distinguished companion for
the world honored laundry
good evening this is frank not
that the sale of them out there are some
of the equation
nam and produce awful editors for this
edition of the launching promised
edward p morgan
and larry leseur
both from the c_b_s_ television news dot
our distinguished guest for this evening
his third level jet
permanent representative of the united
kingdom delegation to the united nations
it's a good one
we're glad to welcome you back to crime
has gone
particularly at a time when i when the
united nations general assembly is
moving into the area of decisions on
korea
itself
of course no news for you sir that uh...
nevertheless many americans have become
what we might call disenchanted with the
whole korean business
and at the outset of this special
assembly session of are greeted with
headlines of differences uh... among the
houses of
cousins between us the police in the
americans
uh... can you straighten this out a
little bit on that sir before we get
into the main discussion
well this question differences it may be
a legitimate to discuss them
but i i i i just think this is not set
but we don't know about to agree
after one of the position
you are the most uh... powerful
individual nation
but leave
and we asked a great power
and we offer them or i would be my guilt
at the center of the commonwealth which
comprises
lenovo i think
a quarter of the population would not
and therefore if we agree
uh... that hopefully well in my view
sick
uh... and and uh... that recently we
must agree that there was no alternative
we've got to agree
but again if we ought to agree
is not a good day just calling also each
other means
logo and a lot just announcing this is a
pieces
it's no good are just announcing it
wasn't journalists or whatever is said
by as some people in great britain
doesn't help at all
with the thing is
look we all are always seven you ought
to be
what does that mean that means that
uh... as democracy as both of us we have
a rub on to express the majority of
people in our country's and quite back
to life a bit
and if we do have expressed majority
opinion in our government's it it's no
you know point in thinking that it's the
end of the world and uh... terrible
happening at we've got to get agreement
as a result of the expression of do this
expression of opinion
and their fault sometimes obviously had
uh... one government has got to differ
to do is another government allies there
is no partnership
not in the far east
of course
we wouldn't dispute
that you after your enormous sacrifices
and career have got to use a a major
interest in the forties but nevertheless
i suggest we who've also made sacrifices
into other commitments quite
considerable we have alright to express
our point of view when we don't see why
our opinion should not at least it out
so that when they get down two specific
questions
the united states strongly opposes the
participation of india
a british commonwealth nation in this
korean political conference that follows
the armistice sometime next fall all
this fall
now could use
did you get a statewide
the uh... united kingdom's pollution is
on the participation of india in this
political conference on korea yes i
worked
that across means that we must explained
to us what general position is
and we think that uh... in the first
place united nations passport a great
victory and repelling aggression and
pushing back the aggressively came from
intending to back which is not the only
old mission decision
western vino
uh... in a terrible situation with a
central role threatening celebrity and
diplomatic and interrupted it diplomats
are grabber that brings up a point right
there around that it seems to me is
quite important to americans and that is
that
we have been taught in school
uh... and this in a general life that
when you go into a game or into a war
you're supposed to win it
a lot of people think that there has
been no victory in career that we
haven't won it
but it seems to be bothering i don't
agree i think we have one
and so far the games being played we
won't be repelled aggression
but what is not having a field mission
water on objectives no i think the
dollar detective skills and ahsan
objectives of the site
and i'm sure that's been set on both
sides of what is the objective the
objective is the unification by peaceful
means
that is on objective well if you will
not wall because we're not going to go
on with this war having one of wilkey
sent out to do
what is the the procedure dad usual
glendale unified riyadh by peaceful
means of a bit by peaceful means
peaceful means mean it means by talking
by negotiation bartels got its name
but you don't have to go station it was
great and the best possible way as a
sailor's get
uh... into the negotiation antibody who
can effect
uh... one way or another affect definite
lead
the situation in korea
and have an effect on the peaceful
unification
that is why we support the indians and
indeed the russians veterans also
question who doesn't go see asian eyes
closed
the united states for example is
strongly opposed to the invitation to a
soviet russia
participate in this political conference
on korea as a member of the united
nations side
how do you feel about that
well we get ah...
uh... we think is still under the strict
interpretation article sixteen it's true
that two sides
one of those who fought on both sides on
one side really koreans in the
north korea and the communist chinese on
the other
sixteen nations and the strict
interpretation of my time as the two
sides
that may be so he wouldn't dispute
but if you want to have a successful
negotiations with peaceful duplication
grip
that popular to get in some other people
too
and we think the general assembly of the
petty right to recommend and recommend
because of recommends must be accepted
by you
the chinese
this you can recommend that other states
we have a great interesting russia but
that's what's the point of going to be
sent well you don't think that letter
should be exposed as a
apartment fictitious role as a neutral
in korea bear no responsibility and to
actually sit on the aggressor side of
this political conference i didn't say
she was a a neutral and career
that she had little to do the needful
does not find
but i think that presence is necessary
if you want to get his head solution by
peaceful means adolescent lesser grade
what would you say sir that
one of the things that might be
bothering americans at this point
particularly is that
there there are frayed that a a
what might be called a round table with
groceries and
uh... would be one of appeasement of
this and that uh... out of discussion
they might lose something no i don't
think so at all
what is appeasement
uh... appeasement i suppose is doing
something dishonorable in order to
secure solutions something that you
wouldn't agree to our model on the
grounds
that would be appeasement went into
negotiation or not compelled to accept
in it and uh... dishonorable
and you realize made snowfall moves none
of us would agree to anything disarm
anti-japanese that
there's no reason why we shouldn't have
been into negotiation
despite another thing the decision is
not appeasement
when you get uh... projecting beyond
this immediate
united nations assembly meeting and into
the political conference that is very
said come sometime this fall
uh... what are the mechanics are as you
see it as they're going to be uh... an
agreement uh... a majority agreement on
a piece uh... document or will it be
uh... matter of an axis between
britain the united states and western
allies on one side in china and russia
on the other
moslem get into negotiation i hope we
shop
into the question of the anybody
imposing their will in may the
resolution which racial shortly
discussed in the united nations name dob
that they shouldn't be any question of
uh... majority view preventing how can a
majority of you prevail
uh... you save uh... solution is not
acceptable to you or indeed that the
other side it can't be imposed
and that was laid down every country
participating in the
indian negotiations
fish are not the bombed except by an
incision except by john concerned that
applies to you
whose does one have to make the
in dubious inference from that sir that
there is a great possibility that there
will be in agreement with this rock
along with the divided korea as we have
with the divided germany guess is that
possible
you know he's my shouldn't roger
submission who knows what may happen
control
was again when you think that the korean
peace conference to take place this fall
should be strictly limited to the
question of the unification of korea
orchard go into other questions in the
far east
well i think uh... certainly to start
off with the question of korean
that's what led down the aisle
mississippi would love to have the right
to profit
now if there is any progress on that and
if
tank too big it considers possible if
that should be in a disposition to to
discuss other questions in the far east
left of the job either in the context of
this uh... particular negotiation or in
some other uh... that is possible island
extended that i think certainly ought to
concentrate on korea best trying to be
my preference i quite agree with that
and then i think if they find anything
out of the question do you think
possibly
go into them
was a good and i guess you question
about regina uh... her majesty's
government recognizes red china and
uh... is my understanding that
your government would also like to see
regina
admitted and united nations
we recognize regina
because we think we're joined in the
government of china
and uh... you mean the communists and
government intriguing we think it is the
government of china
constantly
well fortunately or a person there
i don't get into the model question
until uh... myself we never have we
think that the two years actually it
people who are government china now
that's always said nothing else massey
question if the regina were admitted to
the united nations
invent think that they would do it then
the defense britain
and i don't know that whether they were
well they they were
was a change in chinese representation
in the united nations would depend on it
and can be in the united nations
we will never happen i don't live with
and have some extent on
on how the chinese behavior needs
negotiations and other things that
brings this producer grab on to a final
question
most of our experts agree that
three overriding communist strategy is
one to try to divide the allies what's
the british reading uh... on that effort
as of now
well i think i think the soviet
strategies unbounded to develop the
island's
and to trying to make nato
australia and divide awesome you have
separate someone objective
boxset let them know that present in
this conference or not is another
question despite audible and a six five
hundred since they were not present
in this negotiation they would invite
you and ask for more suggestions they
were thank you very much sir good word
for being with us on
gone to school
the opinions that you've heard our
speakers expressed tonight
an entirely their own
the editorial board for this edition of
the loan gene promise bill clause
edward the login and larry let's uh...
both love the c_b_s_t_v_ new stuff
our distinguished guests
cross-examined jet
permanent representative of the united
kingdom delegation to the united nations
if you are contemplating the purchase
price of a very fine watch
it would be proper devote to compare the
facts about long g_m_ watches
with the fact to have
any other watch
and you'll find that the facts about my
own gene
are convincing proof of surpassing
quality
actual evidence that in the laundry much
you'll have one of the finest eyepieces
inmate in all the work
foreign competition with the world's
best boxes
multimap to the loan of one for
excellence and elegance and worlds that
brown prices and twenty eight gold
medals
or accuracy highest honors from the
leading government observers
for dependability the position of
leadership in sports
in aviation
and inside
though lol gene is one of the very
finest watches made anywhere in all the
world
along gene watch is not excessively
expensive
because
you made by an oem
all by and probably give alone jing
watch
for as little as seventy one fifty
this is important
whatever the price
every launching watches manufactured
to the highest standards of quality
which had made long gene the world's
most on ad watch
the world's most on again
long-chain three near a product of the
loan gene with na what's happening
since eighteen sixty six
maker of watches all of the highest
character
we invite you to join as every monday
wednesday and friday evening at the same
time well-known jane brownsville
a television journal of the important
issues that they are
broadcast on the top of launching the
world's most only watch
and what nor distinguished companion
lots
to the world are launching
this is like not reminding you that
laundry man with no watches are sold in
service from coast to coast
by more than four thousand leading joel
will proudly display this emblem
agency or long-chain witten or what